in the last series of examples we go
into month two with a hundred dollars in
cash and the way we set up the example
we spend $200 in months two and what
we've been doing so far is you're saying
oh that gives us that gives us to a cash
balance of negative $100 at the end of
month two and that's a little
unrealistic I kept it simple here and I
allowed us to have a negative cash
balance just for simplicity but usually
you will not see a negative cash balance
the fact that you have a negative cash
balance and you're allowed to operate is
essentially means that someone is
lending you money so to make this
example a little bit more realistic
let's imagine a situation so in month
two you only have $100 the person that
you're catering for that you're buying
these two hundred dollars of supply for
they're not going to pay you until next
month so you tell the people that you
need to buy stuff from look I only have
$100 I have this customer I'm doing the
catering inform this month can I pay
$100 for to you this month and then
maybe pay another hundred dollars to you
next month and let's say that they agree
to that so in month two on a cash basis
instead of spending $200 you're actually
spending I'll just write over it you're
actually spending $100 and then in month
three you'll also spend you'll also
spend $100 now this will change your
cash accounting numbers this will now be
negative 100 and this would now be five
hundred dollars but the more important
thing is I want to show you how this can
be accounted for and accounts payables
the fact that you essentially told your
vendors even though you gave me $200
worth of stuff I'm only going to give
you $100 now and I'm going to give you
$100 later that means that you've
increased your accounts payable by a
hundred dollars you've increased this
liability that you owe things to other
people so let me add accounts payables
over here so I will add it I'll add it a
row I'll do it on both of these diagrams
so I'll just call it accounts I'll just
do a period so I don't have to write the
whole thing accounts payable accounts
payable and going into the period you
didn't have any accounts payable and
then now that you're essentially
borrowing $100 from your vendors you're
you're allowing to push back when you
pay them you now have an accounts
payable of $100 and I'm not going to
work through it on all
this stuff over here but let's see how
that would have affected the income
statements and the balance sheet so over
here all of a sudden you had another
liability accounts payable is a
liability you have an accounts payable
liability of $100
so this sorry at this point we had no
accounts payable liability and then
after the end of the month we have an
accounts payable liability of $100 we
owe $100 to our to our vendors and our
cash is now at zero so notice it still
does not change our equity we
essentially added one hundred to cash
and then we added $100 liability they
cancel out if you take if you take now
this part right here all of the assets
are four hundred four hundred minus 100
and liabilities still gets you to three
hundred in equity but now the
reconciliation is to go from $100 in
cash to zero cash we're not allowing
ourselves to go negative and the reason
why we can do that is we actually have a
source of cash we have a source of cash
so let me erase that and then let's add
a line right down let me see if I can
add a line right over here so we could
say accounts accounts payable increase
and now this is a source of cash and it
might not be obvious we're increasing a
liability but it's a source of cash
because we're we don't have to use our
own cash by increasing the accounts
payable it's allowing us to not use all
of our cash so we have an accounts
payable increase of 100 so this is a
source of cash so now the cash cash from
operations 200 at income minus 400 plus
100 this whole thing is now minus 100
cash from operations so you start with
$100 you use 100 our ending cash is now
zero and it all works out